що
девіз нашої партії ми обираємо життя
Чирик тому вона і не думала про політику
тпр молода мама Ольга варчук у нас 20
комбінаті в будинку scrat і права. вигляд
молодіжної партії України
саду символу відома партія проводити
активно продаю ворони to tell
якщо покарай на її рішення та краще ти
сюди політичної начебто
вийняв із шутери місяці навіки краматорськ
досвідчений сопить контролем сепаратистів
минулі влади павана розчарувалася
мовчазного бездіяльність теж ми в
годину на базі реальність так само побачиш
гола свою роль особливі вокал і заміських
і прийшли в нашому з туапсу поїхав і все
було поки кличу
ми вдумайся чика ти ми поважаємо шуму йому
дістати не знаю дістати не посилання
достатньою енергією щуп змінить а
краматорськ на кришці не краматорськ
найкращу сторону мер так розширити анашкін
сам краматорська обіцяє 10 партій
змальованих на нинішніх виборах
немов боротьба that shit є між
розуму політичному це бурому і біженці
партії опозиційний блок і наш край 40
людина і до хат атаку зайвих радіо
налив конкуренті їм складаєте
представник та блоку солідарність даного
цих краматорська проводжаючи при палаці
китайця
нашому краю чи то опозиційного блоку
заданому донецького комітету вибірки
україни квіти смуги 5 травня для всієї
області
старий формат я буду на matiz брехт та
спливши і з території тут харчування на
скільки
чому ноги були такі лідери нову я
кістки зможете тут роботи ми будь ними
збирали там намагаюся 4 може тут
проукраїнська біг-6
ми вкажемо вчитель не чудес не буває і
АГС-30 жовтня у побутуванні фонду
демократичні ініціативи 59 сотки
вибірки у донецькій області
до синяви значилося закону волосся увата
мати занадто вив і канаду світу нехай буде
їхніх політичних партій і що був ще до
лінії фронту
тим вирішую тиша у що ви не вибираєте
Краматорська у розвинутися 40 кілометрів до
передове зради пофарбований вірять на все я
піду волосся я прийду голосу вату однак
чи пофарбував у всіх там навчальному пеклі
вероніка мокші нікому я в загарі на пі
дон та вибори за ти хто у bell тінях я на
пі до голосувати я хочу змін нафарбований
кращий бік
коротше коротше за нових голосуватимемо
та ального рачок вид молодіжної партії
україни , начебто an act in adult хитайся
доктора завантаження влади однак за два
дня до дня голосування та прогнози не над
оптимістичніше яскраво може не пориви штати
і 20 5 вид сотки